[音楽]
スマートフォンほとんどの若者が持っていると言っても過言ではない必需品のアイテム
である
特徴すべきはこの大きな画面そのままを触っている時突然上からやが降ってくると
しよう
普通だったら画面に穴が開いてぶっ壊れてしまうがもし
べく薔薇でもつけていると守ってくれるそう
それがいい
液晶
をフィールダーううん
今日はスマホの液晶フィルムに少しでもヒビが入っていたらすぐ捨てて新しいのに変え
ます肇社長ですもうこれくらいの日々でも僕は無理っすねー
ここら辺もちょっとかけてますねいうで見かけるんですけどもう iphone 5
画面
バキバキに割れてる人よくいませんか
だぎゃーない防ぐ変えすぐ打つすぐ帰りなさい危ない
生まれ程度マジで危ないですからやっぱりスマホ触ってると破片が刺さって気がするか
もしれませんなんで僕 iphone のこの画面の液晶肥料が割れているのが本当に
嫌で高い扱うんですがガラスそうかたガラスフィルムみたいなの買って貼ってちょっと
落としてちょっとでも破片入ったらすぐペリッパイプたから
と書けますからねせませんその時は
譲れませんってぐらいちょっと iphone の保護フィルムすごい大切だと思って
ますから発皿とかね指英語がサプリすると本当刺さって痛かったり調べたりするんで
まぁガラスフィルムだと特に気をつけたほうがいいかなと思っております田治米社長
ですとりあえず撮っていいですか
ほんとも割れてるのは無理すぎてここねのバケは下手にあなたもう
[音楽]
本体は綺麗なんでいいんですけどこんだけ割れちゃってるとこことが作った曲ですこれ
ガラスのフィルムなんで破片がよく落ちたりするってマジであるんですねこれどん
ぐらいからめっちゃ強い
なんか山陽線ぐらいのめちゃんこかたやつだったんですけども破れたよね別にそうなん
でめっちゃいこうとしたわけでもないんですけど気づいたらバレてて落としたら
戦線をとしました落としたら割れちゃったってどれくらいの凶
何だろうせっかく生まれたのがあるんですと強度測ってみようと思います脳がの家を
落とすみます
[音楽]
4日
全然はれんな
これぐらいだったら大丈夫なの高め顔としま
[音楽]
哀れないや強いんだろう
あっはぁああいいで縫われちまいました
がらせだから周りも自分は連打こうやってみます
背景感じで生まれちゃうんですよねー怖いですねはもうほらほらもうガラスの破片が
ヤバイ
どんどんバリバリになっていくんでもうダメですからやっぱりどうしたらもっと
iphone の画面を守れる素晴らしい液晶があるかと色々調べたんですけども今の
時代
iphone の歴史をフィルムパーラないらしいです春よりもっと素晴らしい方法
あるみたいなので買ってきますこちら
画面が割れてしまうあなたで僕でコード画像英知みたいなめちゃくちゃかたやつらしい
んですよ
これ何と思うそれフィルムを貼るとかじゃなくて塗るらしいんですよ
脱ぐという眺めちゃん語かたいっていうのを聞いたんっある
a 中身がすごいもうなんかに貼らないんだって今何ピンセットまでついちゃって手袋
までついてるよまじ大進歩してんな新時代の最強の液晶フィルムは
塗るんです液晶フィルムなら開けたらて袋入ってるのそうないんですよで早速やってみ
ましょう
まずはまずはを装置ですね
まだ汚れを完品きれいにしましょう数名済み混ぜ家来に拭き取ってください
アルコールくせえけどこれでいいんだすげー食べてる汚れを落とせるにあれこれを使い
ということです
3コキではこんな綺麗なもあるってくれた目もキレイ
完璧ですねはい
これこれっぽいなこれをどうやらぬるっぽいですうーんめっちゃんこくさい
劇薬ですね多分俺だったやばいどちら余力これでそれよってお経
えっは彼らはからね滑らせます術の種
これほれこれがフィルムになるのかな
クロスで講座 a を確認すり込みます分かりました
これで絵を描くように刷り込むらしいですそんなに遠隔用例
[音楽]
はいっ
でっ
きましたディスプレイかけてきます本当に入っ
ディッシュに水を空けております
え
この工程を後5回ぐらいやるらしいです
だけでないようなこれふざけてないよねほんとに大丈夫ならこれガラスコーティングの
不安だけどやるしかないよざ同じ事をやっていきます
ん
おおおおおおおおおおおおお
おっを切った
4分
いいめっちゃ不安なんだけどこれだってさ何も変わってなくのパットに
声塗るのコア塗るのはからねぇ塗って吹いて縫ってくれての繰り返して全然実感が沸か
なかったんですけどちょっと触ってみます
ん
できてるのか不安ならこれ本当にまずは
b 明王にんですけど若干のなんか浮いてる段階が患者するんでしょ
俺ちょっと不安だよこれわからないもんだってわかんないもん
はから乳母になるわからんうわーっ
果たしてこれが本当にガラスコーティングされているかどうかって実感がわきません
まあけど多分大丈夫でしょなんじゃないジョブと思います今度は大丈夫
まずで不安なんだけどマジでわからんけどちょっとしばらく使ってみようと思います
おっ
まぁでもなんか強そうね多分
うわぁああああっ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ